I have a clip for you today.
That brings together all of the worst of the
American right wing, it puts together conspiracy
theories, the inability to accept defeat,
the inability to think critically, the inability
to simply push out these tired Republicans
sycophants that continue to plague them, and
the cherry on top of any good right wing conspiracy,
antisemitism.
This this video clip has it all.
Newt Gingrich, former Republican congressman
and speaker of the House and all around terrible
person, went on Fox News and said that Joe
Biden's corrupt election theft was financed
by people like George Soros.
Of course, you have to do it for any good
right wing conspiracy theory.
The money has to have come from the Jews.
It's almost a prerequisite.
Here's Newt Gingrich.
Your thoughts on that message, Newt?
Well, it's a nice sentiment first to go out
and the Democrats steal five or six states,
and that's what Republicans believe we're
watching and we think we have evidence of
a lot of it.
Then you turn around and you say, let's forget
four years of Nancy Pelosi.
Let's forget four years of impeachment, harassment,
opposition, hostility, hatred.
And now that I've won, why don't we dance
together?
I think he would have to do a lot to convince
Republicans that this is anything except a
left wing power grab financed by people like
George Soros deeply in at the local level.
And frankly, I think that it is a corrupt,
stolen election.
It's very hard for me to understand how we're
going to work together without some very,
very big steps.
Now, Newt is right about one thing.
We're not going to work together, definitely
not with him.
But how is it that it's always one or more
rich Jews financing the whole operation?
Now, it's true.
Jewish Americans are one of the most consistently
liberal voting groups.
They overwhelmingly voted for Hillary Clinton
by even more overwhelming numbers based on
early exit polls.
Jewish Americans voted for Joe Biden.
But that doesn't mean George Soros and quote,
people like him are financing imaginary voter
fraud, but they always go to some group of
Jews to tie the theory together.
Now, Newt claims there's voter fraud evidence
there isn't.
He claims states were stolen.
They weren't.
He claims Biden stole the presidency.
He didn't.
But then in pops that what weaves it all together
is a Jewish man put up the money to do this.
And I actually fear that mentioning that makes
the whole thing more credible to some of these
right wing nuts.
I worry that he's putting it in there because
it probably helps.
It's actually irresponsible to continue putting
Newt Gingrich on the air.
And Fox News is going to have to figure out
what is their play going to be for the next
few months.
But the message for us as we see this and
we are going to have videos later today of
Mitt Romney and John Kasich, which will stun
you or maybe they won't.
What we have to understand is these are awful
people and they're not going away.
Democrats can't go soft.
The left can't go soft thinking.
Well, now that Trump was such a disaster and
Biden won will be able to work productively
with Republicans.
No, no.
The election was funded by people who donated
to Joe Biden.
I think it was like thirty seven dollars each.
And it is mostly people on the left, the rare
anti Trump Republicans or anti Trump Republican
groups.
These are not our friends.
Newt Gingrich is not our friend.
He was not anti Trump, by the way.
And we are going to talk about that because
there's a certain naiveté about bipartisanship
that's spreading.
And guys, it's not going anywhere.
But as far as George Soros goes, he's I think
he's 90 years old.
The idea that George Soros is financing the
theft of individual ballots like a ground
game of stealing a few thousand ballots here
and there to steal states.
Give me a break, guys.
It's just another anti-Semitic conspiracy
theory.
And after the break, we will talk about these
anti Trump Republicans are not our friends.
More on that coming up.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.